[Music]
alright meanwhile Saturday Night Live
will make history this weekend by going
live to both coasts at the same time for
the first time ever executive producer
Lorne Michaels book Jimmy Fallon - host
for the third time and Harry Styles will
be the musical guest so are you excited
are you nervous yeah totally I'm just
honored that Yvette Lauren asked me and
we're going live coast-to-coast for the
first time ever yep Jimmy's taking his
alma mater into virgin Live territory
SNL has an ear on both coasts at the
same time in its 42 year history the
whole show's gonna shine basically
senator live has never been loved smart
moves since this season SNL has racked
up its highest ratings in two decades
and now the whole country gets to be in
on the joke simultaneously but Jimmy
David during his six-year run Fallon
became famous for busting up
[Applause]
hi I'm Jimmy Fallon he and Harry Styles
couldn't even get through their new
promos without the giggles what Michaels
loves it when people break Carrie fellow
SNL alum Chris Kattan remembered how
everybody wins when Jimmy loses it
including in this scene
it really was honestly hard to remain in
character with him this force gene
convinced I saw the scene Jimmy broke
and everybody broke I'd be doing myself
a disservice and I remember this band
invited perform the hell out of this
that's part of the reason why let's get
discipline but good racier late nights
kids get toned down with half the
country now watching earlier I would
think they would if they wanted to in
the end cuz you can push the envelope at
11:30 that you can't really push it yeah
below the surface there is a frenzy of
activity
[Music]
you